bonjour bonjour est-ce que vous
m'entendez bien
est ce que le son est bon merci de me
répondre sur le tchat
ok
oui très bien ok super merci beaucoup de
vos réponses alors je suis sandrine
charge de travail pour la chambre de
métiers d'artisanat de l'essonne au
service communication
bienvenue et merci de participer à cette
quatrième édition de ma journée
découverte des métiers de l'artisanat
qu'organise la chambre de métiers
d'artisanat de l'essonne en partenariat
avec la faculté des métiers
le cfa bâtiment de brétigny sur orge et
les apprentis d'auteuil qui se situe à
marcoussis
les cinq web conférences qui nous
proposons aujourd'hui enfin que nous
avons proposé puisque aujourd'hui c'est
la dernière fait à ce moment là c'est la
5ème et la dernière
ce
sont proposés dans le cas semaine
nationale de l'apprentissage qui va se
dérouler jusqu'à vendredi samedi inclus
me semble-t-il
soro ont été consacrés aux métiers du
goût de la fleuristerie
je suis plus de l'automobile de la
beauté est là aujourd'hui nous allons
aborder le sujet du bâtiment avant de
commencer je voudrais juste vous dis
vrai quelques informations importantes
sur le secteur de l'artisanat et
l'apprentissage qui attire de plus en
plus de jeunes et des adultes en
reconversion
l'artisanat représente
1,3 100 millions d'entreprises
artisanales en france 250 milles en
ile-de-france et 31000 en essonne pour
plus d'un tiers des plus d'un tiers des
apprentis sont formés par des
entreprises artisanales autant dire que
l'apprentissage c'est quand même l'adn
de l'artisanat
il faut savoir également que la
formation en apprentissage offre de très
belles perspectives d'avenir pour les
jeunes soient en tant que salarié d'une
entreprise soit en tant qu'entrepreneur
dire que la création d'entreprise
l'apprentissage peut aboutir aussi sur
la création d'entreprise sachez que 80 %
des apprentis trouvent un emploi à cdi à
l'issue de leur formation en
apprentissage dans les six mois et que
41 % des dirigeants d'entreprises
artisanales ont été apprenti donc tout
ça est très lié l'apprentissage
l'artisanat même combat voilà de quoi
alimenter nos discussions et peut-être
de susciter quelques vocations
chez vous dans le public vous êtes
nombreux à participer beaucoup de
classes de collège au total sur toute la
journée nous avons eu sept cent
cinquante participants donc cette
quatrième édition est un succès et nous
amène à la
réédité l'année prochaine on pense
place maintenant à la présentation de la
filière des métiers du bâtiment donc
j'accueille autour de cette table cécile
lavaud qui est chef de projet au cfa du
bâtiment de brétigny bonjour cécile
bonjour j'accueille par ailleurs
frédéric
diodore qui est formateur qu'au pôle
finition alors finition finition plutôt
dans le bois non peinture un staff
peinture et staff hockey et julien qui
est apprenti menuisier en quelle classe
julien
bp menuiserie d'accord est ce que tu
peux nous dire un petit peu quel a été
ton parcours avant d'arriver à un bébé
menuiserie
[Musique]
oui et
quatre ans à est-ce que tout le monde
sait ce que c'est qu'un staffeur
ornemaniste
qu'on en parlera enfin d'accord ok
j'ai voulu aller dans un métier qui m'a
qui me passionnait vraiment donc je suis
cherché j'ai trouvé la menuiserie j'ai
vu passer un serbe est menuisier en deux
ans et après je savais pour
perfectionner bp et bp c'est quoi ces
brevets brevet professionnel merci
julien
alors écoutez on va commencer n'hésitez
pas à poser toutes vos questions sur le
chat qui est dédié à cela où vous
trouverez des informations des contacts
non de
back office qui sont là vont poster
énormément de choses nous allons avoir
quelques quiz au cours de cette
conférence et n'hésitez pas à vous poser
ces questions là on y répondra addition
des 40 30 40 minutes de conférence et
sachez que cette webconférence est
enregistrée et donc elle sera elle fera
partie d'une communication sur tous les
médias de tous les
acteurs participant à cette journée tous
nos partenaires et sur le site c'est ma
essonne
voilà et bien cécile je te laisse la
parole et je t'invite à nous présenter
un petit peu le sujet bonjour à tous
donc je me présentais le sommaire on va
vous présenter donc l'apprentissage
ensuite nos métiers donc aux fins de
visite virtuelle du cfa vous présentera
le btp cfa de brétigny les métiers du
bâtiment donc on n'explique pas ce que
c'est cette affaire ornemaniste on aura
ensuite les trois conseils de cécile et
on vous donnera des informations pour
aller plus loin alors être apprenti
l'apprentissage c'est
intégrer une entreprise
suivre donc être salarié d'une
entreprise suivent vous pouvez passer ma
page suivante s'il vous plaît
voilà donc suivre des cours théoriques
et professionnelle au sein du centre de
formation donc du cfa et puis donc
d'aller en entreprise donc fleuri de
l'alternance c'est pour nous une semaine
au cfa et deux semaines en entreprise
donc c'est préparer un diplôme et à la
fin avoir une expérience professionnelle
reconnue puisque ce ne sont pas des
stages mais ce sont bien
du travail en entreprise alors quand on
dit toucher un salaire
cécile ça veut bien dire qu'on est
salarié de l'entreprise au même titre
que n'importe quel autre salarié tout à
fait ça correspond ou signer un contrat
d'apprentissage qui est un contrat de
travail et vous avez cinq semaines de
vacances comme tout salarié et vous avez
donc des droits des obligations est donc
derrière vous toucher un salaire et vous
cotisez vous commencé à cotiser aussi
pour votre retraite etc vous êtes maman
salariés d'entreprise sachant qu'on
verra tout le long de votre
apprentissage vous être accompagnés vous
êtes salarié mais en formation vous avez
un tuteur le voile employeurs maître
d'apprentissage qui vous accompagnent
tout le long de votre formation avec un
formateur référent
au cfa appareil qui fait l'articulation
merci cécile alors je vous invite à
répondre à répondre au premier quizz qui
figure dans le chat la question est
l'apprentissage est réservée aux élèves
qui ne peuvent pas continuer des études
en enseignement général ou qui ne peut
qu ils ne sont pas motivés pour
continuer les études à votre avis est-ce
vrai l'ouest faut
donc la réponse c'est le quiz a été
passé avant la réponse est faux
évidemment
l'apprentissage je n'ai pas que dédiée
n'est pas dédiée aux élèves en
décrochage
l'apprentissage et les déliés à tous
partis souhaitent apprendre un métier
c'est ça c'est ça être motivé pour
apprendre un métier et donc voilà il ya
partir de là qu'on s'est pas être en
difficulté nécessairement c'est tout
simplement intégrer le marché du travail
tout en continuant à aller à l'école et
puis pour apprendre un métier avec ses
mains quel qu'il soit voilà donc on va
effacer le lit de la mauvaise image que
l'apprentissage avait vraiment sur les
épaules depuis des années c'est à dire
que c'est la voie de garage elle est
dédiée aux élèves qui suspend pour
qu'ils sont pas bons qui sont pas bons
en classe de très concerné vous êtes des
troisièmes des quatrièmes donc c'est le
moment de se dire qu'est ce que je vais
faire les prochaines qu'est ce que je
vais faire dans deux ans je pas bon à
l'école val et leurs profits sage non il
ya des très bons élèves en général qui
ou alors des deux des élèves en
décrochage mais parce que voilà ils sont
attirés par d'autres d'autres voies plus
manuels la plus technique qui se
retrouve pas dans les matières générales
que les matières générales suffisamment
sont abordés la de manière pratique
c'est sûr manger français mathématiques
c'est par rapport à un métier
donc il ya toujours ces bases là mais
qui sont en relation par rapport à
presse qui est fait sur le terrain
conduites sur des choses beaucoup plus
pratique moins théorique mais on
continue à faire tout comme l'histoire
géo il ya de l'anglais aussi voilà donc
on a de plus en plus de personnes qui
ont déjà un bac ou qui ont déjà tout des
diplômes dans les mains et qui
souhaitent tout simplement
rendre un métier pourquoi parce que
l'artisanat est en train d'avoir le vent
on couple ça repart et nous on le voit
dans les inscriptions des créations
d'entreprises on voit que l'artisanat
vraiment le vent en poupe parce que
c'est concret et c'est voilà c'est un
métier passionnant
et qui après la formation que trouver du
travail et ce comme on a vu derrière
s'est passé vraiment une expérience
professionnelle puisque pendant tout le
long de votre formation vous êtes son
entreprise donc au début on vous montre
ensuite vous accompagne mais vous faites
tout seul donc après le jour aux amis
aux diplômes vous pouvez aller
travailler
place maintenant peut-être à la
présentation du cfa de brétigny sur orge
c'est un cfa qu'est dédié aux métiers du
bâtiment donc on vous voit vous passez
une petite vidéo de quelques minutes et
on revient après
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mieux
et
pour
[Musique]
alors btp cfa de brétigny
donc on vous a dit on est spécialisée
dans les métiers du bâtiment donc notre
public dont on accueille tout public
aime particulièrement les jeunes de 15 à
29 ans en alternance en contrat
d'apprentissage chez des adultes en
contrat de professionnalisation est en
formation continue nos formations vous
du sap et brevet professionnel bac pro
bts et on propose également des titres
pro pour les adultes nos métiers maçon
peintre applicateur de revêtement
staffeur ornemaniste plombier
chauffagiste technicien en chauffage
climatisation énergies renouvelables
menuisier fabricant agenceur métallier
électricien maintenant on va voir tous
les métiers donc on va commencer par le
gros oeuvre et en particulier le maçon
et on a souhaité vous emmener avec nous
dans les ateliers et avec les apprentis
qui vont présenter leurs métiers à
travers une vidéo
bastien g 15 ans
j'ai voulu venir en apprentissage parce
que j'ai versé le manuel ça m'a toujours
plu je suis venu dans un effort
d'apprentissage avoir conservé avoir un
diplôme
j'ai découvert la maçonnerie en travail
qu une personne de ma famille puis le
week-end et sur les chantiers ça m'a plu
et de là j'ai voulu faire un
apprentissage en maçonnerie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
un métier compliqué mais j'aime dans mon
métier parce que je suis passionné c'est
ce qu'on aime faire construire et
travailler avec les mains
surtout le terrassement c'est un métier
qui est bien on voit vraiment créé les
bases de ce pont va construire
- tu prochain projet parce que si jamais
tu t'es trompé en calculant
où tu prends l'échelle de base toujours
en référence
c
donc il à la base de toute construction
c'est lui mon a vu enfin kim et qui
montrent les parpaings met en place les
fondations
et ils sont amenés à bouger à travailler
à l'extérieur ou chez en intérieur de
fonction de la demande des clients en
les diplômes donc
la base premier niveau diplôme donc le
sait le certificat d'aptitude
professionnelle donc le ca paix qui se
prépare en deux ans ou là on apprend les
bases du métier et ensuite le brevet
professionnel donc il ya un diplôme de
niveau bac qui se prépare après un ca
paix en deux ans et là qui vous permet
d'avoir plus de responsabilités
et de pouvoir par la suite créer votre
entreprise on propose de plus en plus
comme je disais des formations si pour
adultes donc à titre professionnel à
rentrer et on proposera chef d'equipe
rose oeuvre et assistant chef d'equipe
pro oeuvre
maintenant on va voir les métiers de
l'énergie électricien
bonjour je m'appelle télé j'ai 25 ans et
je viens vous parler de mon parcours et
de pourquoi j'ai choisi le cfa de
reading pour pour ce parcours alors
quand j'ai vu 16 ans j'ai été orienté
dans les métiers du sinaï en
aéronautique
je trouvais pas de patron pour
m'orienter en masse abri donc par des
vosges avait choisi cette voie qui ne me
correspondait pas du tout donc quand
j'ai eu 18 ans j'ai décidé d'arrêter
d'en montrer dans la vie active en
intérim dans les domaines du bâtiment
au bout de plusieurs années je me suis
dit qu'il fallait que je passe un
diplôme pour pouvoir évoluer devenir
vraiment quelqu'un ans dans l'un de ses
métiers et pour avoir des possibilités
de carrière donc j'ai choisi le cfa de
brétigny sur orge pour une alternance
dans le domaine de l'électricité
après c'est une autre voilà
2 2 à 2 par la dame
a parlé de croisade à un petit défi de
cette fois été la grande les objets
alors en tant qu'électricien on
intervient à tout moment du chantier dès
le départ quand il ya personne on vient
mettre le courant vont bien mettre en
service une installation temporaire pour
que le chantier puisse se dérouler dans
de bonnes conditions pour qu'on puisse
avoir de la lumière du chauffage donc
chargé des outils branches et des outils
donc c'est vrai que mon intérieur que
tout début et ça va jusqu'à la toute fin
puisqu'on est quasiment les derniers à
passer quand les peintres ont fini leur
métier leur boulot on vient mettre les
derniers cash de finition sur les plis
sur les interrupteurs donc c'est vrai
qu'on est présent tout au long du
chantier à tout le monde
je suis d'accord sommes retombés ensuite
si je vais sur un an et messieurs vous
serez d'autant plus ce soir votre bouton
poussoir
en mai fais ce boulot
voilà
donc donc l'électricien bon travail dans
différents domaines communication
confort sécurité
tout ce qui est domotique sécurité
alarme incendie donc il ya beaucoup de
normes de sécurité à connaître on va
passer à la formation ou pareil c ap en
deux ans résume était comme tout à
l'heure après brevet professionnel en
deux ans la même chose que tout à
l'heure pour les nations
maintenant on va passer ou fluide
qu'est ce que c'est que les fluides
je veux dire après
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle à travers d'ariel
j'ai 18 ans je suis au cfa de brétigny
sur orge en bac pro tisec tout un port
avant de faire deux bacs chez le collège
h au moulin
ça me plaisait plus encore 4e j'ai
décidé d'arrêter sous silence et dans
une troisième partie du coût cfa ils
m'ont acceptée donc je me suis lancé
dans une team qui fait présenter tous
les métiers nouveaux plomberie
électricité maçonnerie et tout j'ai
décidé de me lançant bourrine parce que
c'était un métier manuel moi j'ai
quelqu'un de femmes annuel
[Musique]
oh
le matin je commence à 7h30 donc à cette
heure on arrive au dépôt on demande à
notre patron ce qu'on doit faire dans la
journée clinton a plané nous sommes
internet pour la chaleur on va faire une
chaudière donc nous nous arrêtons ces 91
92 donc on arrive donc en charge du
camion on va dire une chaudière on va
solution seyon d'origine clients opposé
question clients comment ça se passe et
aux soirées nous d'une journée c'est une
bonne journée migrants maximin il y en
une journée une image de la finir ça
devait le client est satisfait
dans ce métier ce qui me plaît c'est
tout c'est l'environnement
et tous les collègues comme ils sont
amis nous spock ce qu'on apprentis on
est ailleurs si l'on est en entreprise
et dans ce métier si tout on est tous
ensemble en paix
alors donc
bah le fluide vous avez vu c'est tout ce
qui est plomberie chauffage
climatisation
énergies renouvelables donc au cfa c'est
le c'est un début c'est le pôle le plus
important
énormément de formation donc le ca paix
chauffagiste donc installateur thermique
en deux ans ou un an installateur
sanitaire en deux ans ou un an suivi
derrière soi par un brevet professionnel
en monteur installateurs génie
climatique et sanitaire soit un bac pro
installateur en climatisation chauffage
énergies renouvelables et à la rentrée
la 2022 on ouvre un bts donc avec plus
de fluides énergies domotique option
génie climatique et fluidique donc cédé
des domaines d'activités qui sont en
pleine expansion et évolution avec tous
cas les nouveaux et les énergies nouveau
type de chalair les chauffe les pompes à
chaleur etc moi j'ai une question cécile
bon comme quoi y'a t'il de d'apprentis
de des lèvres des
avocats la famille alors on est environ
400 450 a franchi un petit peu 450 est
alors toutes ces formations là elle est
ce qu'elle réponde
à un besoin en matière de main d'oeuvre
dans les entreprises comment comment
quel est le
comment dirais-je la géographe et de
mots qu quelle est la réponse que vous
donnez aux entreprises qui cherchent des
salariés qualifiés est ce que c'est un
déficit en matière de main d'oeuvre dans
le bâtiment et est ce que vous y
répondre et ont pas bien sûr là
finalement d'ailleurs à huit vous voyez
notre offre de formation évolue d'année
en année le bts fluides répond à un
besoin des entreprises et répond aussi à
une demande des apprentis de vouloir
suivre un parcours complet formation au
sein d'un même établissement et ne pas
devoir changer d'établissement donc on
s'adapte par rapport aux besoins des
entreprises par rapport à ce qui est
possible
en termes aussi de
technique au sein et d'adaptation sein
du sag fort
donc l'objectif c'est que derrière de
pouvoir il avait bouché
ya plus que besoin de madoff d'ailleurs
c'est fonder ces sinistres et puis c'est
surtout que c'est on le voit ça a évolué
il ya de plus en plus besoin de
d'employés parce que les techniques
évoluent les les adaptations des mots
des maisons les normes évoluent et puis
on a toujours besoin de la vue
d'ailleurs pendant le confinement des
personnes dont on avait besoin qui était
incontournable entre autres c'était les
métiers du bâtiment pour toujours
continuer à travailler des plombiers on
va arrêter de travailler même pendant le
confinement donc sondé des métiers où il
ya toujours du travail on gagne bien sa
vie et ce qu'on n'a pas précisé que
c'est que dans les métiers du bâtiment
en apprentissage au mont gagne 40 % du
smic en fonction même plus en fonction
de son âge quand on commence on sait ap
parce que ce sont des métiers difficiles
mais des métiers et aussi comme on dit
tout à fait en torsion donc on cherche
du personnel donc les personnes motivées
qui se forme derrière sont sûrs de
trouver du travail ça va il n'y a pas de
ya pas de problème par rapport à ça et
surtout les métiers qu'on présente et on
demande aussi de plus en plus de
personnes qualifiées donc c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on fait évoluer notre offre
de formation et d'une année à une autre
voilà on essaie d'évoluer en fonction
des besoins de la technologie et et
voilà et de la transition énergétique
des normes vers lesquels on va de plus
en plus et donc il ya des adaptations
constante aux technologies et donc on
voit dans leur province pour le coup
parce que vous créez toujours de
nouveaux programmes pour répondre aux
besoins des entreprises et aussi c'est
justement ça mais vous mettez le doigt
aussi on me disait tout à l'heure c'est
pas pour les personnes spécifiquement
qui sont mauvais à l'école loin là
puisque il ya des techniques les
spécificités on l'a vu tout à l'heure
l'électricité il ya énorme des choses à
retenir aujourd'hui sur les énergies
renouvelables c'est pareil c'est des
pompes à chaud de chaleur ou des
chaudières qui ont du gaz de
l'électricité qui on voit là où il ya
vraiment besoin de compétence
professionnelle
riche et où il faut intégrer il ya tout
tout ce qui toute la technique donc
on s'improvise pas électriciens maçons
plombiers contrairement à ce que
beaucoup beaucoup avancé et puis aussi
je tiens à souligner c'est que si le
projet de l'apprenti est de créer une
entreprise artisanale puisque ce sont
des métiers de l'artisanat et bien il ne
faudra pas le faire s'il n'est pas
qualifié donc c'est une obligation
d'avoir son diplôme ce sont des métiers
qui sont soumis à des réglementations
match de qualification total et donc on
ne peut pas créer sa boîte si on a façon
diplôme de plombiers menuisiers
électriciens et de se remettre à jour de
manière
récurrente puisque les habilitations
qui permettent de pouvoir aller
travailler il faut que chez des
particuliers haute avoir des aides de
l'état donc tout ça c'est à dire que
même une fois le diplôme obtenu toujours
obligés de se remettre à niveau et de
s'adapter à la technologie
je propose qu'on passe aux métiers du
bois le bâtiment a beaucoup beaucoup de
métiers six sept huit g8 vise 8 cran en
famille et grandes familles de métiers
merci julien ouffe julien g j'ai envie
de te dire ce que tu peux nous présenter
1re ce que c'est que les métiers du bois
pas alors on avait une vidéo à vous
passer mais je pense que c'est
intéressant c'est aussi d'entendre
julian kevala qui prépare à un beau
diplôme et que tu nous en parle comment
comment quand ça se passe
en faire
moi j'ai commencé l'apprentissage
dubois dahmouni z'eric fatiha une grande
grand grand grand panel en mini izri on
se dit misery basset a juste la personne
qui va fabriquer des meubles ou des
portes sa clé sauf qu'ils administrent
et pvc est la menuiserie aluminium et en
bois il ya autant du on peut aller dans
les cuisinistes on peut aller en
on peut aller en décoratifs emportant
fenêtre en parquet
on peut faire du bateau aussi d'aider
fabrication de bateaux voilà c'est plus
dans les secteurs maritime bros mais
l'un existe sur pareil et
il ya donc du mobilier du décoratif ou
on peut tout faire ça qui est que j'ai
aimé dans le bois c'est qu'à partir d'un
matériau brut comme le bois c'est un peu
le façonner à sa manière et on peut lui
donner la forme qu'on veut c'est en
réfléchissant bien à toutes les
contraintes que cela implique la force
que le bois va pratiquer quand tel ou
tel sens de la solidité dans tel ou tel
sens aussi vraiment faire attention à
plein de petits détails qui comme ça au
premier coup d'oeil on se rend pas
compte qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de des
cogitations derrière tout ça justement
julien sam hamad est une question
quelles sont les compétences et
capacités d'un jeune
pour justement entrer dans une filière
bois en bois faut
voir ce petit côté a
ce petit côté créatif on va dire ce côté
créatif et puis ce côté aux fauves
vraiment être minutieux et faire
attention à chaque chaque millimètre
chaque centimètre qui va qui va changer
toute la fabrication et qui risque de le
faire en sorte que le crash soit plus ou
moins résistants ou
qui peut carrément mettre en péril
ouvrage à lui annoncer coup dans les
matières il démâte thiaw laye à des
matchs français a au moins autant vous
dire l'école bas c'était pas ça ne
s'était passé du tout donc basse pour ça
que
je voulais arrêter les écoles j'ai
trouvé cette affaire ornemaniste à
l'époque et jamais ça m'a beaucoup plu
j'ai travaillé quatre ans là dedans
après j'ai voulu changer pour des
raisons personnelles et des années plus
tard maintenant j'ai 31 ans des années
plus tard j'ai
j'ai décidé de me remettre dans le
bâtiment parce que ça m'avait vraiment
plu est quelque chose qui me plaisait
vraiment dans le bâtiment qui me qui
était une motivation et une passion et
du coup je me suis mis en menuiserie et
on les met les matières c'est pas
comment l'enseignement général
ils sont adaptés aux métiers ces
informations c'est les formateurs ce
n'est pas les professeurs les formateurs
sont plus ouverts la forme parce que de
mon point de vue sans plus ouvert et on
a plus de facilité à parler j'ai des
amis qui sont dans ma classe qui eux
avec 7 cette crainte d'être à l'école
assis sur une chaise à écouter un prof
qui parle qui parle qui parle et c'est
pas du tout ça c'est vivre la classe
mahdia un des formateurs comme comme
frédéric c'est ce sont des les cfa sont
des gens qui ont exercé le métier en
tant que salarié ou en tant
qu'entrepreneur et donc du coup ils ont
un autre regard alors s'est il s'agit
pas de critiquer formations n'ont pas du
tout amateur professeur c'est que c'est
pas du tout la même expérience là même
c'est pas la même approche voilà
bah justement vous c'est pas la même
approche un nouvelle approche frédéric
vitoux masse pour paris moi j'ai eu la
chance d'être déjà approché j'ai
commencé comme ça ma vie que ça
commençait à être commentée à votre insu
revanche en tant que staff heures après
j'ai continué à travailler après mance
la paix j'ai travaillé une vingtaine
d'années avec mon père en tant que staff
heures et après je le suis mis à mon
compte c'est pareil j'ai une verte et
une dernière mais compte aussi et
pendant toutes ces années j'ai appris
plein de pratiques différentes et tout
est dans vers la fin j'ai voulu passer
en tant que formateur justement pour
apprendre aux jeunes à
apprendre un métier qu'il était en
développement parce que quand je suis
arrivé au cinéma on était à peu près
quatre ou cinq dans la classe est
maintenant dans le camp l'atelier et
maintenant j'ai une vingtaine de jeunes
donc c'est toujours en progression et sa
mort plus
encore sachez par ailleurs je profite de
faire cette fantaisie
l'apprentissage à vent en poupe parce qu
on enregistre
entre l'année 2020 la rentrée 2020 et la
rentrée 2021 environ en moyenne 10 %
d'inscriptions en plus je pense que vous
avez pas me contredire là dessus ça
c'est les chiffres nationaux alors
évidemment il ya des ya des chiffres qui
sont disparates en fonction et des
filières et des endroits message voilà
c'est puisque l'artisanat a le vent en
poupe et l'apprentissage est en train de
se développer et qu'on en parle de plus
en plus et que du coup les jeunes se
retrouvent vous beaucoup plus dense et
dans une formation comme ça qui sont
d'apprendre un métier concrètement donc
je vais on va on va poursuivre parce que
des métiers après le bois il ya et bien
il ya la victme sion et donc je propose
à frédéric de présenter
la filière pour laquelle vous vous
formez les jeunes alors que le
vieillissement bien le coiffeur et le
pôle peinture cette affaire on sait pas
ce que ça lui enlève le staff c'est un
monsieur le travail du plâtre voilà donc
nous réalisons des corniches et d'écoles
et j'ai l'habitude des moulures donc
nous on restaure aussi qu'on peut
restaurer des châteaux on fait de la
création par et pour des designers on
peut le faire des boules et refaire des
moulages cordes et des fondations de
prestige et on est assis à ses côtés
dans donc tout ce qui est bel
appartement de paris pour justement réel
la restaurer ou enfin de nous alors le
staff c'est une particularité de deux
ans j'ai peut-être dire des bêtises
parce que je suis pas spécialisé mais de
la montre comment dirais-je de l'enduit
de la maçonnerie non non non
ouais justement les maçons monter les
murs les cloisons et tous et nous on
vient souvent habillés tous fine est
arrivé alors on est là dans les métiers
d'un données dans les blés pienaar ou
d'accord donc il ya un volet artistique
à 7 à ce métier là qu'est le métier de
staffeur ornementiste c'est un très beau
métier
oui il ya très peu il y alors il ya peu
d'entreprises artisanales en essonne y
en a quelques-unes on les connaît ils
font des réalisations mais la musique il
y a quelque chose de l'ordre de la
restauration du patrimoine on est
vraiment dans la une niche niche métier
unique moi j'ai eu la chance
dans des musées est
ravi de rencontrer de voir des belles
choses et d'en faire ainsi alors quand
on s'intéresse à l'histoire à
l'architecturé autres c'est
ça crée des liens avec le ce métier là
oui merci
pvs que d'autres choses à dire sur
l'odeur way sur le statique à lyon les
diplomates sont dispensés
et le b et masquer le brevet des métiers
d'art voilà qui se passe en deux ans ou
un non ça dépend le diplomate voilà et
après vous avez les pointures donc là
genre on apprend aux jeunes à préparer
les fonds à enduire
à préparer les mesures à prendre et
après on a essayé de faire des décors
artistique aussi pour
des raisons
liées et puis donner aux jeunes un good
d'un peu de dollar en pâture aussi
d'accord en mai enfin d'une manière
générale la sur tous les métiers dont on
a déjà parlé plombiers électriciens
maçons staffeur un sait combien d'heures
de cours sur la semaine trente cinq 35
heures de cours car tran 16h30 avec la
pause du midi d'accord et ensuite ils
vont deux semaines deux semaines en
entreprise c'est un peu particulier
souvent on trouve le rythme d'une
semaine une semaine entreprises là
quelle est ma raison c'est propre à
chaque établissement d'accord ok et
alors du coup julien ce que toi tu te
retrouves dans ce rythme de une semaine
à l'école avec 35 heures de cours et
qu'un jour en entreprise comment comment
tu gères ça parce que ton entreprise et
peut-être pas à côté de ton école
comment ça quand tu géré ça dans la vie
courante bah moi je la retrouve pas mal
parce que du coup
l'entreprise est souvent mal à la
semaine d'école ça me fait vraiment une
coupure mental on va dire est sacré fort
autres choses des choses que je n'avais
pas forcément entreprises et des choses
que ces entreprises on peut ne pas faire
que de la fabrication la pose de portes
de fenêtres etc si on fait ça pendant
deux semaines et qu'on n'a pas fait que
la brique à sion
c'est agréable dernière est de pouvoir
faire ma fabrication à enlever nos
belles choses et tu pouvoir découvrir
d'autres choses que votre maître
d'apprentissage qui vous a pas d'accord
bon point on sent que tu étais un élève
matures tu l'as dit tout à l'heure 31
ans tu as dans ta classe des jeunes
beaucoup
beaucoup plus jeune que toi du coup
et alors comment ça se passe très bien
au début
mais au final ça fait vraiment une
petite classe ça fait des équipes
vraiment agréable et on s'entend bien on
ira dans une micro famille on à dire
son mari va même avec la différence et
génération on arrive à s'en prendre aux
quelque chose alors tout le coup le
bâtiment on dit que c'est dans le
bâtiment il ya des métiers dits d'hommes
vous avez vous contredire vous n'avez
pas me contredire qu'elle est qu'elle
commence à évoluer en la matière parce
qu'on aimerait bien que y ait plus de
femmes même si on sait que c'est un de
plus en plus de femmes
avaient un master unis songent donc
c'était complètement partie et il a lu
son cercle
d'accord donc on voit plus de fameux
cécile oui en combattant à rui pourquoi
pas ce qu'il ya
la
peinture aussi
difficile
et je trouve que c'est très bien parce
que ça ça dynamise
le métier aussi justement ils sont très
très manuelle c'est très très bien alors
pour le coup là on se dit tous
être sur un échafaud en train de faire
durablement du staff c'est physiquement
c'est compliqué pour une femme venant
pas du tout
cas vis-à-vis des résultats fameuse
dream je suis je suis le premier et j'ai
même des jeunes qui voudraient pas
travailler à l'étranger tout parce que
nous non ce métier là en tant que staff
on peut voyager à peu près dans le monde
entier et il fait des jeunes qui partent
à l'étranger que ce soit des filles ou
les garçons et vient du problème et
alors ça fait partie des savoir-faire
dit ancestraux et français oui qui sont
très très très prisé à l'étranger il ya
beaucoup de chantiers dans des alors des
villes qui construisent pour le touriste
un je pense à aucun pas au qatar mais a
alloué aux émirats arabes il ya pour
julie en chine il ya beaucoup de
demandes de la part des étrangers pour
faire venir des compétences françaises à
l'étranger voilà et le staff on est on
est en l2 afin de lui est-ce que c'est
équivalent dans les autres filières si
déjà ne derrière l'écran aime voyager
aux envies voilà on sait que c'est la
tendance légèrement vi nations les
métiers du bâtiment sont reconnus fin de
formation
congés on faire on va se voir juste
après rapidement enfin rapidement la
métallerie qu'ils peuvent assimiler
aussi un métier d'heure d'ailleurs tout
comme la menuiserie ce sont des métiers
qui sont recherchés aussi à l'étranger
d'ailleurs quand on voyage on le voit
les stars il ya des personnes qui font
la ferronnerie d'art on voit aussi la
restauration de patrimoine niveau qui
ont bien sûr la maçonnerie ce qu on a vu
tout à l'heure donc tout à fait et je
voulais revenir ce que j'ai fait il ya
une petite question pour les femmes
c'est accessible aussi
on a eu des personnes en cumbrie j'ai eu
une question qui a été posée sur la
plomberie on a des femmes tous les
métiers de toute façon aujourd'hui avec
les machines
il n'y a pas de souci de contraintes par
rapport à la force physique j'ai envie
tirs et les entreprises aujourd'hui vont
adapter la manière de travailler par
rapport à l'accueil des femmes et 2
il souhaite en embaucher parce que cela
apporte un équilibre
alors mesdemoiselles derrière l'écran
voilà réfléchissez bien il n'y a pas de
barrière ces métiers là comme les
métiers de l'automobile qu'on a vu ce
matin sont ouverts aux femmes et il n'y
a pas de contrainte aucune contrainte
avec la vidéo et vous entendrez ravet
c'est une fille qui témoigne justement
sur son métier de ce cafard ornemaniste
c'est une fille en l'occurrence et il se
sent très bien dans ces métiers pour
garder de la métallerie la métallerie
donc on travaille le but final on trouve
dans tous les portes l'état je les
portails les objets de décoration les
gardes de corps
donc on propose cette formation en cfa
comme toutes les formations qu'on a vu
depuis tout à l'heure on commence par le
cercle et chez toi mais tu es en deux
ans et après en deux ans on peut
continuer en brevet professionnel
bp
métallier voilà donc c'est dans tous les
métiers sauf en pâture propose le café
et le bp vous avez vu en fluides pose
des fondations en croire qu'ils vont
beaucoup plus loin
voilà donc alors maintenant je vous
propose d'accueillir fait s'il on a pris
un peu de retard cécile qui est
médiatrice de l'apprentissage alors pas
de panique par rapport à son titre c'est
la personne qui fait le lien entre le
maître d'apprentissage et l'apprenti
quand il ya des divergences défi conflit
et elle va nous donner trois conseils
rapidement cécile merci
très très rapide vous embête pas
longtemps bonjour à tous
bonjour on se connaît
oui alors effectivement en tant que
médiatrice de l'apprentissage je me
permets juste trois petits points on va
dire des petits coups de pouce pour pour
bien enclenché son apprentissage parce
qu'effectivement être élève et puis
devenir d'un seul coup salariés d'une
entreprise
eh ben c'est pas facile parce qu'on en
parle comme ça oui c'est formidable mais
c'est pas tous les jours facile dans le
concret donc donc je me permet
effectivement de d'intervenir pour trois
petits points très rapide en premier
lieu il faudrait montrer sa motivation
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire montrer
sa motivation c'est effectivement
je ne sais pas être à leur
être pogné avec son maître
d'apprentissage
ça paraît très très basiques comme ça
mais effectivement ça peut faire la
différence
vous avez tout à fait droit de vous
tromper ça c'est vous êtes là pour
apprendre mais effectivement ce que ce
se montrer va de bonne volonté tout ça
ça ça fonctionne ça fonctionne plutôt
pas mal
voilà donc vous gardez ces bonnes
habitudes de l'école à être à l'heure à
être ponctuel
dans le milieu de l'entreprise puisque
maintenant vous seriez vous serez du
coup payer vous souhaite un contrat de
travail donc effectivement faut en être
conscient et je sais que c'est pas tous
les jours facile donc voilà vraiment
vraiment rester dans cette dynamique là
le deuxième point se passer de son
téléphone portable alors pourquoi je
vous dis ça parce que la majorité des
conflits
effectivement ça ressort assez souvent
et finalement ce sont des conflits
bêtement vêtements vêtements présent en
entreprise donc vraiment garder toujours
se bat cette habitude aussi à l'école
vous n'avez pas votre téléphone et vous
essayer tant bien que mal puisque vous
êtes né avec c'est votre troisième main
et on comprend tout à fait et c'est pas
tous les jours facile quand on reçoit un
message on a toujours envie de regarder
mais surtout fait un très gros gros
effort là-dessus parce qu'effectivement
c'est aussi ces petits soucis qui
peuvent entraîner des conflits et
vous aurez des pauses pour bien
retrouver votre téléphone portable et
vous aurez plein plein de messages et ça
sera très satisfaisant pour vous
en troisième point
est très important ici ces deux sociétés
et solliciter des échanges avec son
maître d'apprentissage
donc effectivement on a pu voir que au
cfa de pressigny c'était deux semaines
d'école de semaine entreprises ce que à
une semaine d'accord donc effectivement
c'est bien d'arriver à la fin de la
semaine d'entreprise avant de retourner
à l'école de faire un petit point des
départs vraiment de d'instaurer ça dès
le début pour qu'ensuite ça soit une
habitude qu'ils soient prises avec votre
maître d'apprentissage de pouvoir lui
parler un petit peu de faire un point de
cinq minutes il n'y a pas besoin de
d'une heure cinq minutes pour dire ce
qui va ce qui va pas
voilà ce qui pêche qui pêchent pas
pour ou s'auto évaluer également et
surtout si le maître d'apprentissage
neu neu neu l'instant repas n'hésitez
pas à le solliciter pour le demander
c'est important ça c'est important pour
votre pour
la bonne marche de votre apprentissage
et
vous allez pouvoir instaurer une
complicité un échange un vrai échange
avec le maître d'apprentissage
et si vraiment ça se met pas en place
naturellement il faudra vraiment le
solliciter et ça sera de toute façon
bien vu on pourra pas vous le reprocher
donc
voilà
en plus
alors par expérience effectivement
surtout dans le bâtiment ça ne parle pas
beaucoup donc
mais c'est pour ça donc c'est pour ça
notamment que je voulais vraiment être
pouvoir le faire effectivement dans le
bâtiment parce que c'est vraiment des
entreprises ou vraiment le la
communication des fois pêche et
subitement on a en parlé et puis en fait
y'a pas de problème c'est juste qu'il
avait besoin de parler donc surtout
vraiment fait le même si ces cinq
minutes voilà fait le voilà bonne
continuation à tous
alors maintenant je vous propose de
redonner la parole à cécile qui très
rapidement parce qu'il faut qu'on traite
votre question on n'a plus que cinq
minutes 6 minutes donc voilà il ya une
journée portes ouvertes on vous invite à
y aller c'est hyper important observé
tout voir et
[Musique]
si vous pouvez pas venir le 16 on vous
invite à venir mais s'incline 6 mars à 9
heures à 12 heures voilà pour venir me
rencontrer et surtout la rentrée 2022
commence dès ses dettes la
maximum
les journées portes ouvertes c'est
vraiment le moment où on se rend compte
de l'endroit ont rencontré professeurs
on se rend compte vraiment de l'endroit
et on apprécie ou pas d'être d'exercer
ce métier on va se dire oui il ya un
équipement top je veux faire ce métier
parce qu'il ya des démonstrations parce
qu'on échange avec des expériences de
professeurs qui sont géniaux donc faut
pas hésiter faut vous déplacer les
jeunes là c'est le moment c'est votre
avenir qui est en jeu donc cac allez on
y va et on en fait plein et après on se
décide et c'est important
de vidéos de témoignages de photos
au jour le jour on sera sa page facebook
toute l'année vous allez tout simplement
sûr que s'il était pcf en ile de france
et là vous pré inscrire v et derrière
donc vous contacter pour faire un
entretien voila voila merci à vous alors
maintenant on a relevé quelques
questions je vous invite à les poser la
très rapidement on va faire vite on a
cinq minutes à peine la première c'est y
at il des matières théoriques à
maîtriser pour intégrer un ca paix du
bâtiment par exemple matt théorique un
match physique etc tiens allez julien ce
qu'il ya besoin de matières théoriques
matières théoriques faire maths français
histoire géo
anglais sur certaines filières et tout
je crois pas c'est des matières
théoriques du métier donc dessin
technologie
mais ne s'impose pas aux autres cf on
est pour y a pas de sélection par avait
pas d'idée ou non ses ventes façon vous
serez à c'est comme si vous commande si
une nouvelle année vous apprendrez même
si vous avez déjà certaines choses vous
les réapprendre et y aura pas de déficit
quoi que ce soit les formateurs sont là
pour qu'ils expliquent nous on assiste
beaucoup sur la motivation vous avez
tout à l'heure c'est vraiment voilà
avoir envie de faire ce métier la
motivation et quand on va vous convier à
venir on vous demandera votre bulletin
de notes mais pour regarder plutôt les
les commentaires les appréciation par
rapport à votre posture parce que la
posture en entreprise c'est très très
important on attaque le marché du
travail et après le reste c'est notre
rôle de vous accompagner par rapport si
vous avez l'envi et envie de vous
investir ou vous accompagne par rapport
aux matières générales et
professionnelles
alors j'ai une question car je vais la
pause et à frédéric quel est le salaire
dans les métiers de la métallerie pour
débuter
aller au bout d'une année d'expérience
en entreprise à peu près mille quatre
cents euros à peu près net net oui et
après ça progresse c'est comme dans tous
les métiers plus plus on devient bon
plus on est payé voilà assez voilà ça
peut arriver jusqu'à 2000 2500 euros
pour certains et puis si vous allez à
l'étranger ou sur des races anciennes
spécifique là c'est assez
particulier
bah après c'est ça peut être en
déplacement ça peut être ça existe
cassis 7000 euros par mois ben oui c'est
bien c'est pas mal
un premier sa gagne combien vous avez
une idée en sortant de l'école
pareillement c'est le problème
[Musique]
ça dépend aussi du secteur auquel on
travaille dans le staff on travaille
beaucoup dans le secteur de luxe on va
dire donc on est juste mais voilà c'est
la plus beau temps canon l'état des
salaires plus gros
c'est vrai oui parce que parce que parce
que là on est dans le coup de la
crise
alors autre question peut-être
quelle rémunération pour un apprenti de
16 ans qui peut répondre à ça et 16 ans
ont déjà été mis sur terre inconscient
du smic ça fait plus de 600 euros
franchement bien 16 ans
environ 60 après ça dépend de ces
entreprises mais faut être vraiment
voilà il faut être ce temps une
entreprise du bâtiment par exemple une
personne qui va dans une mairie c'est
une collectivité et même si le service
technique jusque là pas dans une
entreprise du bâtiment donc on sera pas
sur les mêmes tours par contre si c'est
une entreprise de métallerie purin
artisans etc on sera sur ses bases de
rémunération pas mal à 16 ans à bakel
pour commencer sachant qu'on évolue
voilà alors on a répondu à la question
quel le salaire moyen des métiers
d'électricité des fluides et du bois ces
deux messieurs on gagne bien mais c'est
des métiers qu'il faut aimer et où il
faut s'investir c'est important parce
que c'est vrai que la clé d'entrée on
nous parle tout le temps souvent du
salaire mais le salaire de toute façon à
partir du moment où vous allez vous
formez que vous allez vous faire
reconnaître mon entreprise dans les
métiers du bâtiment gagne très bien
voilà mais il faut pour s'investir et
c'est vraiment sacre en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il ya de l'emploi ça
voilà il ya l'emploi les évolutions s'il
ya les évolutions de devenir aussi chef
d'entreprise j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure 41 % des champs d et chefs
d'entreprise ont été salariés apprentis
avant donc voilà vous avez on est au
mois de février aller aux portes
ouvertes allez vous renseigner et si
vous avez besoin de plus d'informations
tout se trouve sur le site de l'acm a
sur le site de brétigny on vous invite à
aller en gip et au excusez nous on est
un peu en retard et en tout cas merci
pour votre participation et à très
bientôt